[Music]
hey everyone
my name is arjun and today i'm going to
be showing you guys
12 difficult dynamic openings and how
you can beat them
let's get started right away
the first opening i'd like to show you
is called the stafford gambit
and the reason this one is such a
difficult one to deal with
is because it's typically more deadly
than people give it credit for
black is the one who plays the stafford
gambit it starts off with e4
e5 knight f3 knight f6 the petrov
defense
now white plays knight takes e5 taking
the pawn and black plays a move knight
to c6
the most common move here is to play d6
and after white retreats a knight
somewhere
black grabs the pawn back and material
is even
however with the moon knight to c6 black
is voluntary
letting white take and after kicks back
white can just protect the pawn with
either knight to c3 or d3
and as you can see here if you do a
quick material count you'll see white
has eight pawns
compared to black seven and moreover
black has these doubled c pawns which
are typically considered a weakness
however this opening can actually be a
very strong weapon to use at the amateur
level
just to give you an idea of how deadly
this line is let's imagine that a game
would were to take place
black usually plays the move c5 here
bishop c5 sorry
developing the bishop and aiming at this
f2 square
and now there are several moves that
white can play but the second most
common one with over 14 000 games played
with it online
is bishop to c4 and believe it or not
despite white's extra pawn here
as well as these the presence of these
two strong central pawns
black is already better black will play
the move knight to g4 now
double attacking this f2 pawn and the
most natural move to play here as well
as the one that you would typically play
in these types of positions
is castles protecting it with the king
and the rook
but now black comes up with the deadly
move queen to h4
it double attacks the square h2 as well
as triple attacking the square f2
and white can't stop both threats
because of this
black is already completely winning
so now that you know how strong the
stafford gambit is it's probably a good
idea to learn how to defeat it
i recommend the move knight to c3
and now after the move bishop c5 there
are many good options for white
such as h3 to stop this knight g4 idea
as well as bishop b2 but i prefer the
offbeat move queen to e2
the idea behind queen e2 is that after
knight to g4
the most common move white simply plays
knight to d1
protecting this pawn and though this
move may look like it's retreating
as well as moving the same piece twice
in the opening if we continue with the
game we'll notice that black doesn't
actually have much to do about it
if black tries to castle then white can
simply play the move h3
pushing the knight back now white can
play the move d3
preparing for development if black plays
a move like rookie 8 hoping to take
advantage of the
presence of the queen is on the same
line well white can just play the move
bishop to e3
if black takes white can take back with
the knight
and now as you can see white's plan will
be to push the pawn to g3 soon
then the bishop to g2 and then to castle
and there's pretty much nothing that
black can do about it and white is
almost winning in this position as a
matter of fact
and one other typical idea that you
might want to be aware of
is just if black tries to play normally
rather than going for the attack on f2
if black instead does something like
castles white's plans are pretty much
the exact same
white can play move like d3 then
if black tries to play a move like
rookie 8 for example white can just go
for this bishop e3 idea again
and once black's good dark squared
bishop is traded there's not much he can
do to attack
and white's plan remains very simple
with g3
bishop to g2 followed by castles
the second line i'd like to show you is
played by white and this one is called
the stonewall attack
the stonewall attack is a line that
begins with d4
the basic plans for white are as follows
if we imagine black is a queen's gambit
declined player let's say
white will typically develop like this
aiming to bring the bishop to d3 next
so black will develop the knight white
will bring out the bishop
now if black just plays in typical
queen's gambit decline fashion
like this
white will just continue development in
this manner
with f4 next after move like knight to
c6
this is basically how white will
continue to play
if black continues to play passively not
trying to counter white's plans
white will put the knight in the great
outpost on e5
develop the queen and launch a kingside
attack
with the move g5 followed by h4h5 to
come
in this position white typically wins
around 60 percent of games online
which is a pretty hard a pretty large
number
as a matter of fact black is still
better here but it's typically better to
stop white's attack earlier on
so i'm going to show you a way to do
that
if we go back to the beginning just a
note i'd like to mention if you
are a king's indian defense player or
grunfeld player
you won't really need to worry about
this type of attack because once you
play the move g6
after bishop to d3 these two pawns these
two pawns right here
will basically just stop white's attack
but
i'm just going to be focusing on this as
a queen's gambit decline player
so after white's first few moves like
this
i'd recommend the move immediately c5
and it doesn't really make a difference
whether you play e6 or c5 first
i just like this more aggressive move to
be played earlier on
now white will play the move c3 because
if white simply tries to continue the
development with knight to d2
black will go c4 pushing the bishop back
so instead white goes c3 black can
simply play knight to c6 now
continue development knight to d2 from
white
e6 from black now white plays f4
aiming to set this outpost on e5
and instead of the move bishop to e7
which is still very playable
and black will still probably get a good
game i like to move bishop to d6
at first it may not seem like there's
not that much of a difference between
the two moves
but there actually is a pretty big
difference
after the move knight to f3 rather than
simply continuing with a move like
castles
i like to move c takes d4 which is
typically a move black does not play in
the stone wall
however in this case it's a very strong
move
typically if black takes on d4 white
will take back with the e pawn
but in this case he just loses the pawn
to bishop takes f4
and black is just much better up a pawn
with a good position
instead white must take back with the c
pawn here but now
it becomes clear what what weakness this
this recapture has
has provided black now black has
this idea of knight to b4 that could
come later
black can just continue with castles in
this position
white will castle and now black can just
play a move like b6
after knight to e5 the typical stonewall
knight has emerged
but black can just continue with bishop
to b7
and now if white tries the queen to f3
plan which is typical of the stone wall
black plays the move knight to b4
attacking the bishop
now if the bishop wants to stay on its
great diagonal here it has to go back to
b1
but the problem with this is that white
now is that black now has this move rook
to c8
now the knight and the rook are both
threatening the c2 square
and there's very little white can do
about it
if white tries to continue with g4 for
example
one strong plan is to go knight to c2
and after the forced recapture
you can take back and now if white tries
to continue with g5 for example
black just has this move knight t4
essentially stopping the stonewall
attack in its tracks
white's pretty much only other try is to
play a3
hoping to meet the move knight to c2
with rook to a2 however even this is
good for black
since this bishop is blocked it's still
very difficult for white to maintain an
attack
and black can simply continue with a
move like bishop to a6
attacking the rook and getting the
bishop on a great diagonal
black can proceed by activating the
pieces and this bishop will pretty much
never be able to get out again
black should be much better even
possibly close to winning in this
position
the third opening i'd like to show comes
from the scotch
from comes from the scotch game which is
a popular opening for white beginning
with the move one e4
if you were a scotch player you may have
seen this line before
and maybe you've had trouble with it in
the past
the scotch the scotch begins after
e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 and d4
aiming to break open the center
immediately and force some exchanges
black usually takes on d4 now
white takes and now the the most common
moves for black
are to play bishop takes bishop to c5
and knight to f6
however there's this tricky line queen
to h4
that black has pressuring the e4 pawn
though this move may seem like a bad one
since it brings the queen out early and
refrains from developing another piece
it's actually a very strong line and you
need to be prepared for it
if white tries to immediately liquidate
in the center with a move like knight
takes c6
black can already win a pawn with this
move queen takes e4
if white tries to block black can simply
trade queens
and recapture black is just much better
here being up a pawn with a nice
position
instead the best way to continue is what
you might have guessed
why should play the move knight to c3
protecting this pawn
and now the only way for black to try to
justify his previous play
is to play bishop to b4
this move pins the knight on c3 and
therefore
indirectly threatens the e4 pawn
now it may seem tempting to play a move
like for example queen to d3
trying to protect this pawn but this is
not very good since now white's queen is
the one that's misplaced
instead white needs to play the move
bishop to e2 simply continuing
development
now there are options for black and the
most common one is just to take on e4
immediately trying to regain a pawn
another more another less popular option
is to take on c3 first
followed by taking on e4
if black tries to take on e4 immediately
white has a surprising move knight to b5
threatening the c7 pawn and surprisingly
this is actually a very difficult threat
to stop
if black tries to protect it with the
bishop
well white can take the pawn anyway
because if the bishop takes back
the queen is hanging because the bishop
was what was keeping the knight pinned
instead the most natural move may seem
to move the queen back
to protect the pawn this way but now
white has a strong move
f4 after f4
you'll notice that the queen has no
squares it can move to that keep
protecting the pawn
since d6 is controlled and the pawn on
f4 is protected
note that the queen can't take here
either because the bishop will be able
to recapture
because of this the only feasible move
for black is to play the move king to d8
protecting the pawn with the king but
this is clearly not going to be good
white can just castle now and from here
if black tries to develop normally with
let's say move like knight to f6
he just loses the queen
instead black should probably play the
move queen to g6
after which white can simply activate
the knight in the center
or try to attack the bishop and
regardless of what remove white chooses
he will be much better
because black's king is stuck in the
center and white has a lot of extra
development
the other line that white needs to be
aware of is after bishop to e2
the immediate bishop takes c3 white will
clearly take back
after which black can take on e4 with
the pawn
now here once again white can just
castle
the idea now is that like in the
previous position
black's king is stuck in the center for
now and
white can just develop the rook the
bishop and the other bishop
and blacks queen and king will soon
become targets
if black tries to continue development
with a move like this
well black is already pretty much losing
because in a position like this
if black tries to play like 97 for
example y has knight to b5 idea again
forcing the move king to d8
now once again black's king is stuck in
the center and white can just continue
development
with a great position
so the final thing to be aware of is
that after queen takes e4
castles if black tries to take the
knight here
then white can just take back and now
once again the queen is stuck in the
center
the king is 2 and white will gain lots
of time by attacking the black pieces
so basically the moral of this opening
is that you just need to play solidly
and remember this knight to b5 idea to
attack c7
the fourth opening i'd like to show is
one that is often not respected
at all levels however it can be a very
difficult one and i have faced
difficulty myself in facing it in the
past
it may seem like it's not a good line
and it isn't but the move is
g4 called the grub opening
the the idea of the grub is to is to
carefully attack on the queen side
with these types of moves pressuring the
b7 pawn in the process
in fact white actually wins a
significant portion of the games played
in the grab
so i think everyone should know how to
deal with it
after g4 the most natural move is of
course d5
threading to take this pawn immediately
and now white will play the move bishop
to g2 most likely
trying to take advantage of the bishop's
placement on g4
after white recap after black recaptures
now white will play the move c4
attacking this d5 pawn
if white if flak tries to take the pawn
of course he'll lose his rook
after this
so now black should probably play the
move c6 protecting the pawn
and now white and tension become clear
with the move queen to b3
after queen b3 he's threatening this
pawn as well as this one
however typically the more common move
order is to take take
and then play queen to b3 double
attacking
it may seem tempting to try your best to
hold on to both pawns
but this is not actually the correct way
of continuing
black needs to save one pawn and lose
the other and i would recommend doing
this by playing knight tap six
preserving the strong g5 pawn
one thing that you need to keep in mind
is that you should never play the move
e6 here
that's because after queen to a4 black
will lose his bishop and white will be
winning
because of this after the move queen to
b3 i'd recommend the move knight to f6
protecting this pawn black pretty much
white pretty much has to take this pawn
otherwise he has no justification for
his prior play
now black should play the move knight to
d7 protecting the rook with the queen
as well as getting out a new piece
if white simply tries to play normal
chess after something like this
black will have a significant advantage
though material is equal
black has extra development a bigger
center
he has some open files on the queen side
where his rooks will be very active
and white's queen is on b7 which will
provide a lot of extra attacking chances
for black
with both his rooks as well as his minor
pieces
because of this if white wants to try
and gain an advantage
he may try to move bishop to bishop
takes d5
but this move actually loses on the spot
black should play the move rook to b8
now attacking the queen
since since this bishop is being
protected by the queen
the only way to maintain the bishop is
to play the move queen to c6
black should play rook to c8 again now
attacking the queen
maintaining the pressure on the bishop
if white tries to move away
to protect the bishop black has
checkmate in one because the bishop on
c1 is actually hanging
because of this in in this exact
position white
actually can't move his queen anywhere
so here
white's best bet would just be to try
and sacrifice the bishop
and hope to survive this completely lost
position
one more thing to be aware of is that
after the move knight to c3 which i
mentioned earlier
if black plays e6 there is one idea
white has involving knight to b5
here black should play the move rook to
c8 getting the rook active
and now what if white what if white
wants to take this extra pawn
he has both the knight and the queen at
his disposal so i'm going to try and
give you a second to see what you would
do
after either of these moves
we can start with the move queen takes
a7
if queen takes a7 well black doesn't
have any immediate way of gaining
material
however the plan is quite simple black
will play bishop to c5
immediately gaining time by attacking
the queen and subsequently black can
play a move like queen to b6
double attacking f2 threatening this
knight
and preparing for castling note that
all of black's pieces are in their best
positions except for this rook
and this king meanwhile white's knight
is off sides
so is his queen and his only piece that
has been developed is this bishop on g2
so black has very good compensation for
the pawn and he should win this
this position quite easily
if white tries to take the pawn with the
knight on the other hand black has some
concrete tactics that will win the game
the best move to play is rook to b8
attacking the queen
the queen has to move away of course and
if it tries to go to a6
the easiest way is to just play rook to
b6 now
if the queen moves back then white black
can play queen a8
pinning the snipe which will soon be won
by a rook maneuver
if the queen tries to go to c8
attempting to trade itself off
black can gladly do that knowing that
the knight will be completely trapped
after rook to a6
instead after this move
sorry not rook to a8 rook to b8 if white
tries queen to c6
then an easiest then the easiest way is
just to play bishop c5
and after the knight moves away black
can just play a move like rook to b6
if knight to c7 check is played here
which seems like the only challenging
move
well black can just move the king away
with king to e7
and now this knight will soon be lost
because it's surrounded by black pieces
which will capture it with some sort of
sequence
in other words this position is
completely losing for white and he has
pretty much no chance of survival
the fourth opening i'd like to talk
about is another one that's more
deceptive than it may seem
and this one is called the napkins
gambit
it's an opening that white can play
against a two knights defense
which occurs after e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4 knight f6
the most common moves and arguably the
best ones are d3
protecting the pawn as well as knight g5
attempting the fried liver attack on f7
but here white plays the move known as
the white plays the move
with with d4 which is an aggressive
attacking move
that black pretty much only has one
response to which is to take
now there are two options for black for
white
e5 and castles
to play the nachman's in gambit black
white must play to move castles
and now black can just freely take the
pawn
if white tries to win the knight back
black can play d5 and the position
remains complicated
due to this knight being a bit weak
however to play the knackmans in gambit
white plays the strange-looking
knight to c3 which looks like he just
blundered a piece
right if black tries to accept the
gambit
with d takes e3 white has this move
bishop takes f7
very aggressive
if black takes on f7 with the king white
might play the move queen to d5
if black plays a move king to f6 which
is the only move that retains his
advantage
it may look as though he's getting mated
with this bishop coming out to g5 soon
and the rook getting very active and yes
this position
is good for black still but it looks
very scary to play from a human
perspective
because of this i'd recommend
sidestepping all of these issues
and rather than taking the knight with
the pawn i would just take it with the
knight
from here black white pretty much has to
take back
otherwise his queen was threatened and
now black can just play the move d5
gaining central space
after white moves the bishop away black
can simply develop his pieces
and castle black now has one extra pawn
and white has virtually no compensation
meanwhile if black chose to accept the
gambit and take the pawn to the knight
he would have had an extra piece but his
king would have been very unsafe
and i would always prefer this position
over that one
from this position black wins a very
good percentage of the time
around 60 percent and you should be able
to win this game
through through after a long struggle
here
because this is obviously not an already
one position
the sixth the sixth opening i would like
to show today
is play from the black perspective so
we're going to be looking at it from
white side
it starts off with the benoni defense d4
c5
white plays the move d5 now of course
gaining central space
and now the most common moves are to
play d6
knight f6 and e6 all of which would
transpose
into normal benonis however
black plays the strange move e f5 here
in this position
and this may seem like a very silly move
to play since it simply weakens the king
and its only purpose seems to control
this e4 square
however black's idea is that he would
like to get the game out of a normal
benoni structure
if white tries to play c4 like in normal
benoni black can simply continue
development and as one of the main plans
for white in these types of positions
is to play the move e4 all of a sudden
that isn't possible
so black has the game on his own turf
to counter this surprising line i
recommend
completely ignoring black's idea and
playing the move e4
anyway if black takes back
white can play the move knight to c3
threatening to recapture
black should go knight to f6 and now
there are several options for white
the most aggressive of these is to play
g4 threatening g5
and this is also probably the best
option however if you don't want to
memorize so much
you can just play the move knight to e2
preparing knight to g3
and taking on e4 from here only a few
hundred games have been played online
but it should be clear that white will
that white will be much better
after a move like d6 white can play
knight to g3
about to take the pawn black has no way
of trying to stop that
so he can just develop the bishop or
play a move like g6 which is more common
after takes bishop to g7
now as you can see black's king is still
in the center
and this diagonal will be weak white's
knights are pretty good in the center
and he has his backwards e7 pawn which
will be on an open file that he has
pretty much
no compensation for black should be
what should be quite a bit better here
just due to these positional advantages
this is pretty much the only line you
need to know to defeat this system
which is nice since the system has
actually been played a couple of times
in grand master practice
so that's all you need to know to win
the seventh line i'd like to show you is
a particularly scary one to the eye
and it comes from the four knights game
e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6
knight c3 knight f6
now the most common moves here are d4
breaking in the center bishop to c4
and bishop to b5 which is entering
basically a pure four knights
however white plays the strange-looking
move knight takes e5
and this may seem like a complete
oversight did white not see the knight
on c6
but white actually did and white's idea
is that after this
d4 gaining space he wants to go e5
forcing the knight back to a tome square
now does this look a bit more scary
it looks like black only has one piece
developed white will soon have several
of them developed
and it seems like this knight doesn't
have any apparent square to go to
meanwhile this knight can be kicked
around as well with moves like h4 h5
however black still has ideas at his
disposal and it's not all bad for black
black is actually much better here if he
knows the correct continuation
white will usually go bishop to c4
aiming at this f7 pawn
and now black can play the aggressive
move d5
once again this one may seem like a
complete oversight as well
since well white can just take the pawn
but this has a strong idea behind it
black can develop the knight to e7 now
pushing the bishop back in the process
and now the knight can go to the strong
f5 outpost
since the d4 pawn is double attacked
white will have to protect it usually by
the move bishop to e3
now black can just develop with bishop
to b4
his pieces are very active especially
this knight on f5
meanwhile white's bishop on e3 is sort
of playing the role of a defender
and white center will soon be tripped
away at with the move like c5
at a timely moment just as a sample
continuation
castles castles white might try and move
like knight t4
for example but then black can just
develop the bishop to e6
and the position is much better here
black has all of his pieces developed
white's bishop isn't that good on e3 and
let's make sure we don't forget black is
still up a piece for two pawns
so this line is very strong for black
a couple of other continuations that
black that white has
after this line with bishop to c4
followed by d5
black if white tries to take on passat
then black can just take with the bishop
and the knight will have this nice f6
square and now black is up a full piece
with a good position once again
except this time it's only for one pawn
instead if white tries to take with the
knight then this is easier to deal with
black can just play bishop to e6 if
white tries to move like queen to f3
hoping to once again take advantage of
this f7 square
well black just has to move c6 forcing
some trades in the center
as well as likely the loss of the g4
pawn so once again black is going to be
nearly completely winning here being up
a piece for only a pond
those are pretty much the only lines
you'll need to know against the against
this opening which is known as the
halloween gambit
this next line is one that occurs in the
queen's gambit
and black is the one who can play it so
i'm going to be showing you how to
defeat it
what starts off with d4 d5 is the most
common move order
then c4 and black plays this strange
looking move knight to f6
at first it may seem like it just makes
a mistake
because well the reason that we try to
protect pawns in the center
with with other pawns is so that if we
take
then this e4 move is not available
however it once black takes with the
knight
well after takes takes is it e4 just a
possibility
and that would be true but this is
typically what black is hoping for in a
line like this
if black plays the move knight to f6
white can go knight c3
and now black has this idea of e5
don't get me wrong white is still going
to be better here however
it's not that easy anymore if black
tries to take
if white tries to take then after a
queen trade
black will get back the pawn and his
knight will be active in the center
and white still has an advantage after a
move like f4
but white but black still has chances of
of continuing the game with a decent
position
so there's an easier way of getting a
nice advantage
the move c takes d5 is the correct way
of continuing
but now instead of playing immediate e4
it's better for white to simply go
knight to f3
now after this move if black just plays
a normal move
like say for example g6
black white can go e4 and for knight
tries to go back
e5 is met with simply knight takes e5
and once again white will have a big
advantage here
because of this white essentially just
gets a free center in this line
if black tries to defend the e4 square
with knight to f6
simply knight to c3 threatens to go e4
again
if black tries to go bishop f5 stopping
this e4 idea
black and white can take advantage of
the bishop being placed on f5
and play the move queen to b3
threatening to immediately take on b7
from this position black white is just
much better once again
because if black tries to take then
white can just actively develop the
pieces
with a nice position due to this
weakness on b7
and if black doesn't try to stop white
from taking the center
well it shouldn't be too difficult white
can just play
if black tries to counter in the center
let's say y can just push
and now if black develops simply to move
e4
and in this exact position e5 will be to
come
pushing the knight away and any position
like this is going to be much better for
white even sometimes close to winning
the tenth line i'd like to show you is
one that has one of the highest win
rates for black against one d4
and this move and this line is actually
not a bad line
it's just that the name may make it seem
like it's not such a good line to play
it's called the english rat defense and
it starts off with
d4 d6 c4
e5 countering in the center with in this
fashion
now the reason that this opening does so
well is because
after the most common moves he takes e5
d takes e5 queen takes d8
king takes d8 black does very well in
this line
at first it may seem like white is just
much better since the king can't castle
anymore
and white will get some extra
development in the meantime
but as you can see white's plans aren't
so simple
from the black's perspective black's
knight can go to f6
the bishop can go to c5 this bishop can
go to e6
and this knight can go to d7 note that
this knight can also just go to e7
instead
and play the move f6 however for white
it's not as easy to develop
this knight will go to c3 yes black can
go
this knight can go to f3 this bishop
will likely fan keto since
since this pawn on c4 obstruct it
obstructs its development
so this bishop can go to g2 but then
what about this bishop
if this bishop goes to e3 it'll simply
be blocking this e pawn which isn't so
good
if it goes to b if it goes to b2 then
black can play
f6 making it hard for the bishop to get
active
and if the bishop goes to g5 well black
will go f6 anyway
so although this position is equal
black's position is going to be much
easier to play than white
because of this i would recommend not
even choosing to take on e5
and instead i would like i'd like i
prefer the move
knight to f3
now there are only if there's really
only one challenging move
that black has
and that is the move e4 so there are two
options
knight to g2 as well as knight to g5
both of these moves attack this e4 pawn
and since the e4 pawn has pushed past
its normal development square
this can become a target soon
i like to move knight to g5 better and
now there are two options for black as
to how he can try to defend the pawn
black can either play the move f5 or he
can go
knight to f6 if black chooses knight to
f6
white can just develop with knight c3
and if move like bishop f5 is played
simply a move like queen c2 for example
would be pretty good
since this pawn may fall soon
instead if black chooses to move f5
which is probably a better one
then now white has some options once
again
i like to move simply knight to c3
if black tries to push away this g5
knight white will gladly do so returning
to h3
and now the knight to f the knight will
soon move to f4
from here if black tries to develop
normally would let's say a move like
knight to f6
then black can play white can play
knight to f4
and soon after he'll play d5
centralizing the queen
and even potentially getting this knight
onto this great square
on e6 where it may soon become an
octopus
this position is going to be pretty good
for white nothing not winning or
anything
but definitely advantageous and white
will have good chances compared to black
in this line
that's pretty much everything that
you'll need to know for the english rack
defense
since there are no major tactics or
traps you'll need to watch out for
the next opening i'd like to show you is
one that you've probably encountered
several times
and this one is called the alban counter
gamut
the albin like the others sorry is
a very dangerous weapon that sometimes
people don't give enough credit to
but white should of course take the free
pawn and after the move d4 by black
trying to gain space white should play
the move knight to f3
after this white black will play the
move knight to c6 protecting this pawn
and if black if white simply develops
normally
like this trying to just get the pieces
out
then black has a lot of stuff he can try
to do
for example if a position like this were
to occur
white still has an advantage but as you
can see black has a strong central pawn
and material moreover is equal
so i think that the most important thing
to know in the album counter gambit
is that you should try and pressure and
possibly even win this g4 pawn as soon
as possible
so one good option here is to play the
move
well you can first play the move g3 of
course
but then after a move like this you have
options with like knight d2 for example
if white if black tries to play knight
g6 then white can simply go knight to b3
triple attacking this pawn and as a
matter of fact there's actually no way
for black to protect it
if white takes if black takes then
something like this might happen
and from here this d4 pawn is slightly
weak
and if black tries to play move like c5
white will soon chip away at the center
like this
however there are also other options
instead of playing the immediate g3
another option is to go knight to d2
immediately and after something like
knight e7
white can go knight to f knight to b3
attacking this pawn
now if black tries to protect it now
white can simply just play g3
because this e5 pawn is going nowhere
since this knight won't attack it
and now i can simply finish development
castle
and eventually return to trying to card
its d4 pawn
and this this type of setup is one that
i prefer over the last one that i showed
instead if black tries to target the e5
pawn once again with knight to g6
white can simply take on d4
and now white is once again just going
to be up a full pawn
this should be a pretty good position
for white to try and win because black
has
small amounts of compensation due to
due to the spawn on c4 being potent a
potential target
however this does not nearly compensate
for the loss of a pond
and white can have a nice easy time
trying to press this for a win
the 11th opening is another one that i'd
like to show for black
and it occurs in the italian game which
is one of the most popular openings at
all levels
after e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4 bishop c5 we enter
the italian game
white now plays the move c3 which is the
most common move and the idea is that
eventually white will want to press with
the move d4
black should play the move knight to f6
and here the most common move and
probably the best one as well
is to go d3 and eventually after a lot
of maneuvering and developing
white will eventually try to get in d4
meanwhile black has plans of his own as
well of course
however to play this next opening which
is called the molar attack
black goes white goes for the move d4
after e takes which is pretty much the
only good move here
takes bishop to b4 the most common move
here and probably the best one is to go
bishop to d2
if takes takes white has a big center
but black can play the move d5 now and
the position is pretty much
equal
so from here white should play the move
knight to c white will usually play the
move knight to c3 though
and the idea behind this is that white
voluntarily sacrifices this pawn
since the knight is pinned but after the
move castles
now white's idea is that he wants to get
some extra development
now the most natural move may seem to
may seem to be just takes on c3
but this move actually only promises
equality for white for black
sorry after takes takes
white sacrifices the rook on a1 with
bishop to a3
and now if black tries to be greedy and
take the pawn
after this line black will win back all
of the lost
white will win back all the lost
material
and more and now if we ignore everything
else
white has a queen and knight for two
rooks and two pawns
which is not a straightforward win by
any means but given the weakness of
black's king
white should easily be able to win this
exact position
so because of all of these lines back
from this position i don't recommend the
move knight takes c3
and the most common move as well as the
best one is to take with the bishop
now one option for white is to play move
d5
which is the most common one entering
the molar attack
now black white is threatening to take
this knight on c6 as well as the bishop
so black white should try black should
try and save one of them by playing
bishop to f6
now the most common move is to play rook
to e1
not even choosing to take the knight yet
but rather to attack a different knight
white black should now choose to save
this knight on eset on c6 by moving it
to e7
white will now take the rook take the
knight on e4
and black should play the move d6
because otherwise
white might end up playing d6 with a
cramping position
after d6 there are a lot of options for
white
two of the most common ones are queen to
e2 and bishop to g5 bishop to g5 being
the most common one
after bishop g5 the easiest way to
continue is just to play bishop takes
knight takes and now either castles or
h6 i prefer h6 personally
now one idea for white now is to play
the move queen to e2
which will essentially just transpose
into the other lines that i'm showing
white black should take on g5 and white
will play rook to e1
triple attacking on this file
black's only option is to play bishop to
e6 and now after you take black can play
f6
if we do a quick material count we'll
notice black is up one pawn
but his advantage will be more than that
you'll notice that this one pawn on e6
is basically blocking up all of white's
pieces
in other words white would actually want
this pawn to be removed because his
position would suddenly become much much
better
however with the pawn on e6 black will
have enough time to safely get castle
and get his king out of the center
before trying to push with his central
pawns
instead in the queen e2 line things
could potentially be very similar
if black chooses to castle white might
go bishop to g5
after takes takes in this position white
can
black can just go knight to g6 though
saving this knight
and now discovered attacking this one
and once the knight moves away
a move like bishop to f5 simply has a
very good position for black being up a
pawn
with no apparent weaknesses and white's
bishop on c4
is basically biting on granite with this
pawn on d5
to some takeaways from the molar attack
would be that you should remember
that on c3 you should probably take with
the bishop because
the knight takes c3 lines have a lot of
extra traps and disguises hidden
and just another key thing to remember
is that first you save the bishop and
then you save the
the c69 but after this point
things aren't too difficult for black
since most of the correct moves are just
the ones that are the most common
as well as the most intuitive
the final opening i'd like to show is
one that i'm sure we've all seen before
as well as lost two and this one is
occur
occurs in the two knights defense once
again and this time it's what it's from
the white's perspective
so after the two nights occurs
as i said before a good move is to play
knight to g5 double attacking f7
black can play a tricky line called the
tracks or counter gambit with bishop to
c5
from here it's pretty clear that white
can just take this pawn
and you may wonder well what is black up
to with this bishop c5 move
white will white will often take with
the knight and after
that black will play the move bishop
takes f2
surprising surprising white
if white chooses to take back all of a
sudden black is doing pretty well
because after knight takes e4 if the
king moves away
then you can see that white has that
black has a lot of threats here
the position is still around equal but
definitely it's easier to play black
so in this position you may know that
the best move is to play king to f1
however after queen to e7 now black
still has lots of ideas trying to take
advantage of the weakness of the white
king
so though this is a completely playable
position probably it's better to just
avoid all of this
because of this i recommend the much
simpler move bishop takes f7 instead
though it's not nearly as ambitious as
knight takes after a move like king f8
white can simply bring the bishop back
now it's pretty clear that black has to
try to do something if black does
nothing
his king can't castle and he's also down
a pawn
if black tries the same idea with bishop
higgs f2 which a lot of people have
tried
white can just take with the king and
now if white if black tries knight to
trying the exact same idea his knight
can be captured
because of this bishop takes f2 is
simply not an option in this position
anymore
so black can try with queen e8 to get
something going on the king side
however white can just castle now
and after move like d6 white can just go
d3
and since his king is castled there's
not going to really be any danger with
the queen
and white is just much better with an
extra pawn and what will soon be a very
nice and winning position
so those are the 12 openings i'm going
to be i have showed you today
i hope you all enjoyed this video and
thank you all for watching i'll see you
guys next time
you